c'était le 29 janvier dernier les
services municipaux de où ils ont été
victimes d'une attaque informatique
directeur des systèmes d'information
externalisés pour la commune
thomas hébert a accompagné la
municipalité face à soeren somewhere une
cyber attaque avec une demande de rançon
le credo d'auteur et a pu pénétrer le
système d'information et le réseau à
travers une faille du firewall dus
principalement en fait à l'obsolescence
des matériaux et une mauvaise mise à
jour en fait des différentes versions ça
bloque complètement toutes les
applications métiers d'habiles les
finances les ressources humaines mais
également tout ce que j'ai une ville
donc le la gestion d'état civil le
cimetière l'aide sociale la police
municipale etc pour remettre en place le
système thomas hébert a pris contact
avec l'entreprise auxi box situé à
guyancourt
il y a quelques semaines cette société
spécialisée dans la cybersécurité a
lancé une offre gratuite
une solution de redémarrage de
l'activité après une attaque
l'idée c'est de leur permettre de
s'équiper maintenant rapidement devoir
prendre une décision facile
afin de parer à l'urgence puisque il ya
une épidémie aujourd'hui qui se propage
l'épidémie de rands somewhere qui se
propage aussi bien dans les hôpitaux
sujet est pris à bras le corps par les
pouvoirs publics que dans les
collectivités territoriales
cette société guyancourt toise a déjà
reçu plus d'une centaine de demandes de
la part d' administration publique